today is not just monday it is cyber
monday traditionally the biggest online
shopping day of the year and retail and
retail analysts rather predict it could
generate get this 11.3 billion dollars
in online sales that would be a rebound
from slower than expected black friday
sales it was the first time online
shoppers spent less than the previous
year the day after thanksgiving meg
oliver is inside amazon's giant
fulfillment center in robbinsville new
jersey where my name might be on a few
of those packages may good morning
good morning tony here at this
fulfillment center there are more than
14 miles of conveyor belts helping
deliver some of the first packages of
the day out to customers
many retailers started advertising their
cyber monday sales early including
amazon whose sales started on saturday
while hiring workers has been a
challenge amazon said it brought more
than 45 thousand people on board last
week retailers across the country have
told consumers to buy early due to
supply chain issues and staffing
shortages according to adobe analytics
hard to get items remain an issue for
customers with out-of-stock messages in
november up 124 percent from
pre-pandemic levels the highest out of
stock items are appliances electronics
housekeeping supplies and home and
garden the top selling products are toys
books video games and appliances
shipping companies say they expect to
deliver a record-breaking number of
packages this holiday season fedex and
the u.s postal service say you need to
ship by december 15th if you want your
package to arrive on time for christmas
and if you're looking for a tv today is
the day to shop shoppers can expect the
biggest price drops on tvs today gail
boy those belts are moving awfully fast
be careful
we all hate a out of stock message too
thanks a lot